suzanne legault en a gros sur le coeur
son enquête permet de démontrer que la
grc a bel et bien et détruit des
renseignements réclamé en vertu de la
loi d'accès à l'information au sujet du
registre des armes d'épaulé je n'ai
jamais vu quelque chose de la sorte
avant même l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
qui allait éliminer le registre
l'exemple des pôles
la commissaire avait obtenu la garantie
du ministre de la sécurité publique que
la grc conserverait les données ce qui
n'a pas été fait il n'avait pas le droit
de les détruire
voilà que le gouvernement conservateur
en profite pour inclure dans son projet
de loi de mise en oeuvre du budget une
disposition qui annulerait
rétroactivement l'infraction que la grc
aurait pu commettre c'est essentiel de
mettre fin avant qu'elle soit deux
précédents on est en train de mettre en
place
mettre de l'avant quand le gouvernement
peut simplement par un projet de loi par
un par une loi devant le parlement et
les mines et rétroactivement
potentiellement des activités
criminelles
l'opposition est furieuse c'est grave la
façon dont ils couvrent qui le
gouvernement et cette île de protéger
demande ce libéral les conservateurs
minimise la portée de ces mesures et par
un simple correctif administratif le
qu'horizon une échappatoire qui se
trouvait dans la loi et monsieur le
président un cas les libéraux vont ils
arrêter de s'acharner
quand les chasseurs les pêches pour la
commissaire à l'information rien ne
justifie la décision du gouvernement
suzanne legault compte se battre et
lance un appel aux députés lui ou elle
devra se regarder dans le miroir et
devront se demander si celle ci c'est
possible en toute intégrité en toute
éthique en toute légitimité en toute
moralité de voter en faveur de ses
dispositions là mais avec un
gouvernement majoritaire les chances que
cela se produise sont pratiquement
nulles en attendant la commissaire
évalue ses recours le bras de fer est
elle évitable
ici marc godbout radio canada ottawa